le droit de materis si vous voulez c'est
que les informations qu'elle a donné bon
mon expression ses pilotes y en a eu
absolument aucune influence mais
c'était une personne qui a voulu un tout
petit peu berner les services de
renseignement elle a très rapidement
compris que en leur donnant des
informations elles pouvaient pouvait
avoir de l'argent donc pouvait continuer
sa vie la vie qu'elle avait avant la
guerre parce que mon mathari lorsqu'elle
arrive à paris cc c'est au début du
siècle elle est très jolie fille qui me
faisait en 1915 un énorme à l'époque
c'était énorme
voilà ce que faisait donc un succès fou
enfin le ton pass est bon le l'étoile de
mata hari pas lire un petit peu bon et
elle est recruté par les services
allemands justement la guerre est là
elle comprend que ben ça peut il permet
de retrouver son lustre d'antan son
lustre d'antan c'est quoi ces fréquentes
et bad et des officiers qu'elles adorent
à la vie elle-même sa fréquenté les
beaux hôtels etc
donc voilà elle profite de ce truc là à
un moment elle devient agent double tout
simplement parce que ben ça arrive à
tout le monde
elle tombe amoureuse d'un permis c'est
une très très très nombreux amants d'un
d'un capitaine russe et pour pouvoir le
rejoindre
elle demande
sauf conduit aux français donc le chef
du deuxième tour euh l'époque qui devait
s'appeler dupont lui dis ok mais move
travailler pour nourrir voilà comment
elle devient gendre mais bon encore une
fois est la rue berné les services en
leur donnant des informations remonte de
très faibles niveaux qu'elle recueillait
seul ouvrier est véritablement ça n'a
pas influé se régale
[Musique]